talent-wise i think i do things better
than other people doing this draft i'm
not really with all the words about
actions
i'm definitely a believer in like look
good play good feel good
i always feel better when i got a nice
cut i feel a lot better on the court
when i'm looking better you know i could
do things
you know cozy and just comfortable and a
nice t-shirt some jeans and you know
something like that
what sets me apart is definitely my
basketball iq
i watched a lot of film was a lot of
basketball constant communication with
people who have been in the game for a
long time
growing up as a kid i used to like play
a lot of video games and then like go
out in the driveway
and just do what i just did in the video
game
coming into the league i'm just trying
to be as successful as i possibly can
i obviously have my own self motivation
to prove myself right
and then prove people wrong rookie the
year 100
the goal if it's not then i don't think
you should be doing this
boy look good don't before y'all try to
you know copy my hugo boss look
i'm out of here